c'était une cinquantaine de personnes
rassemblées ici devant la mairie de
bondy pour soutenir gabriel un
adolescent de 14 ans interpellés entre
la nuit du 25 au 26 n'est alors qu'il
tentait de voler un scooter sa famille
l'a récupéré à l'hôpital jean verdier
très grièvement blessé à l'oeil avec un
traumatisme crânien et trois dents
cassées parmi les participants
aujourd'hui aussi bien les membres de la
famille de l'adolescent que des
personnalités politiques qui sont venus
ici exprimer leur indignation face à ce
qu'ils considèrent comme des violences
policières que rien ne justifie je
propose de les écouter on entend sous le
choc
ça peut arriver aujourd'hui à d un temps
froid aussi
stop à la violence
c'est inadmissible merci tous autant que
vous êtes ici il ya quelque chose de
très grave qui se passe dans notre
police qui est dangereuse maintenant
pour les jeunes j'imagine que pour eux
la plus là pour la plupart ça doit être
difficile de sortir de chez soi et
l'accord qui doit être en eux la peur
pour les familles et voilà donc c'était
important d'être là en soutien à gabriel
demain pour à ça traoré la mémoire damas
et pour la justice aussi on a besoin de
justice la famille de l'adolescent a
déposé plainte auprès de la police des
polices l'igpn
et puis parmi les personnes qui
participaient au rassemblement
plusieurs d'entre elles ont prévu de se
rassembler ce mardi pour une autre
victime de violences policières adama
traoré décédé lors d'une interpellation
en 2016